the roll it was a seven the demogory it
got me when looking back on season one
it's mind-blowing just how much
foreshadowing there was to the story and
characters to come the amount of
personal development our heroes have
gone through by season four gives us
direct parallels to their original
introductions
there's this thing called acting and you
just gotta do it
number one millie bobby brown you think
you can steal from me boy
what the hell this is the first scene we
actually get to see eleven but the
moment before that in hawken's lab says
a lot that's where it came from yes
and the girl she can't have gone far
this is the first glimpse of the upside
down that we get to see and then
following we see a young scared little
girl in a hospital gown just trying to
find some food eleven has no idea just
how powerful she is at this time in her
final major season four moment she uses
those same powers that caused all that
season 1 terror and destruction to bring
max
11 is definitely sure of herself now how
to gain that autonomy and become this
woman on her own this season really digs
into that number two finn wolfhard
something is coming
something hungry for blood mike really
grew up over the last four years in
hawkins
going from a young timid little boy to
we have to kill it and we will
we will finn wolfhard could never forget
shooting that very first scene in mike's
basement part of that reason being it
was the very first thing he did for the
show he was so nervous he and the rest
of the guys couldn't stop laughing we
were all i think just really like just
scared we didn't have any rehearsal or
anything it's pretty insane to see mike
going from dungeon master to confidently
plotting vegna's demise yeah i like to
plan ahead i'm like a criminal
mastermind number three gayton matarazzo
what if it's the demogorgon oh jesus
we're so screwed if it's the demogorgon
talk about foreshadowing gayden
matarazzo's character dustin has a
similar path of growth as finn
wolfhard's character he goes from nerdy
dungeons and dragons kid hanging out in
his friend's basement to a major hawkins
hero his final scene in the fourth
season is definitely more on the sadder
side he isn't just innocent mr munson
he's he's a hero
it wasn't a demogorgon that screwed them
this time around though i kind of
deserve it at that point number four
caleb mclaughlin don't be a [ __ ]
fireball him it's crazy to see how much
these characters have grown throughout
the years caleb mclaughlin's first scene
where he's freaking out about the
demogorgon and dungeons and dragons
seems like an entirely different person
than the one with a swollen eye reading
passages from the talisman to max in her
hospital bed we were babies you know our
mindsets are totally different from now
but we've grown so much and evolved the
passage he's reading from the talisman
is actually pretty significant to the
story speedy i'm here my god
i'm here in the territories this part in
the novel is when the main characters
step into their version of the upside
down it almost directly correlates to
what max and the others have been
through i would say this is the most
vulnerable season that everyone's had
like this is this season is answering a
lot of questions number five no wish nap
well you're actually i don't know
fireball they have to roll a 13 or
higher ah poor sweet will he has no idea
he's totally gonna get taken to the
upside down in a bit will's character
has had pretty significant growth over
the past four seasons
including being a total champ about
everyone including the writers for
getting his birthday it's clear from his
first few lines in the show that he's
very timid shy and perhaps a bit
indecisive moving forward into the end
of season 4
we have to kill him yeah he's done being
victimized he's ready to stand up and
end vecna's torment over him once and
for all oh my god it's like it's chaos
but i love it number six
sadie sink maxine
it's max sorry nobody calls me maxine
max's character is definitely a fan
favorite it's hard not to root for her
after all that she's been through
because i'm scared i'm so scared i'm so
scared it's interesting how the tables
have turned here in comparison to you
should have seen the look on your faces
and you who screams like that you sound
like a little girl
though we're sure lucas would rather
scream like a little girl any day over
watching one of his best friends suffer
max's feisty introduction in season two
definitely carries throughout the series
as well as her immense bravery when it
comes to protecting her friends
it being a series the characters really
grow and develop and each season they're
almost like a different person number
seven priya ferguson you are such a nerd
shut up no wonder you only hang out with
boys
how are we not going to love the
sarcastic intelligent erika sinclair her
character definitely holds true to her
first introduction she loves making fun
of her brother but she does end up
developing into a core member of the
gang so there's that there are quite a
few wins they wouldn't have gotten
without erica by their side
number eight joe kiri
i really like
seriously i have to go
ladies man steve harrington it's
actually such a twilight zone moment to
look back on season one steve because he
has truly grown and matured so much is
that supposed to impress me
you're not by the end of season four
steve is no longer just a ladies man or
a babysitter he's in the words of eddie
munson
steve harrington is actually
a good dude in his final scene at the
food and clothing drive we're definitely
not looking at the same guy from season
one now looking back actually at the
first season you do see a real
significant change in number nine
natalia dyer
hey nancy
there's a slice left if you want it
sausage and pepperoni hold on
speaking of blowing vechna to bits who
would have guessed that mike's rude
teenage sister would play such an
important role in saving the world she's
gotta stick up her butt yeah it's
because she's been dating that douchebag
steve harrington again such a twilight
zone moment hearing steve and nancy get
talked about like this nancy like erica
found herself playing an important role
in her brother's friends group she
initially wanted no part of steve
he's
actually
grown up quite a bit you know
it seems like the steven nancy saga
might not be over just yet nancy really
comes into herself in a different way
this season through that and she's quite
fearless number 10 charlie heaton did he
come home or not i don't know charlie
heaton did a great job of portraying
will's older guilt-ridden brother when
asked if he's woken well up for school
he says he hasn't he's making breakfast
he's trying to avoid his tasks like
babysitting by saying he thought they
could use the extra cash that's why he
wasn't home to watch will the night he
vanished because he was working though
jonathan grows a lot in the series it
seems like his avoidant ways still seem
to surface in times of discomfort like
when nancy asks him about his college
acceptance letter
no
no
not yet
number 11 winona ryder will didn't spend
the night
no he left here a little bit after eight
we are huge fans of anything wynonna
ryder does her character joyce goes
through so much throughout the series
from trying to convince hopper she's not
crazy to literally saving him from the
tortuous russian base he was trapped in
also from her first scene where she's
concerned about where will is to
neutralizing a demogorgon with no time
to spare
well she truly steps into her
well-deserved role as a hero
it's all woven together really
beautifully and
still has that stranger things heart
number 12 david harbour the first time
we meet hopper definitely says a lot
he's passed out on the couch surrounded
by cigarette butts and empty beer cans
he doesn't have any dialogue because
he's very very alone later on in the
episode we learn more about his gruff
demeanor he lost his daughter we
sympathize with him he's heartbroken
which is what makes this final scene in
season 4 so special
thank you
number 13. maya hawk i'm robin pleasure
to meet you robin couldn't have started
off in a more iconic way all she does is
roast steve throughout their work shift
you are oh
sick popeye yeah yeah i can count steve
obviously wants to date her he wants to
date everyone but throughout their time
together she ends up coming out to him
and he becomes her first and truly one
of her best allies oh you really
shouldn't oh but i did
but i did just deserve it number 14.
joseph quinn i'm gonna flip in the bird
i'm gonna snatch that diploma we know
eddie munson was only around for season
four but he made a huge impact on us as
fans he starts off as this bad boy
jokester who freaks everybody out
because he plays dungeons and dragons
and could possibly worship satan due to
these misunderstandings he spends most
of his time on the show running for his
life but in the end he's a hawkins hero
i think it's my year anderson
i think it's finally my year
number 15. eduardo franco his funny
friend argyle has been taking us to
school his hair is longer than mine we
absolutely love argyle he and jonathan
are a total comedic dream team like a
shrink you know like he's there to
listen to whatever jonathan's got going
on in his mind by the end of season four
argyle has definitely earned his good
karma
absolutely
eden i
i will do anything for you but even his
love for eden can't stop him from being
jonathan's best bud
what's
he doing looks like he's gathering
mushrooms after looking back at
everyone's introductions to the show
it's clear just how much all of these
characters have grown matured and
stepped into their true role as the
heroes of hawkins who's your favorite
character in stranger things